На думку західних експертів, те, що вагнерівці, як вони стверджують, захопили Бахмут,
не має стратегічного значення. Нині там лише купи зруйнованих будинків.
Військової промисловості немає, сировини немає.
Бахмут вже давно перестав бути важливим транспортним вузлом для українських військ.
Крім того, найближчий населений пункт Часів Яр добре укріплений і знаходиться на височині.
Тобто росіянам зараз треба буде воювати проти пагорба, проти гори.
До того ж далі там територія з лісами та річками, що погано для нападника і добре для того, хто обороняється.
Тобто моя оцінка така, що Росія зараз спробує зробити з Бахмута другий Сталінград,
але це зовсім не відповідає тому мінімальному оперативному значенню, яке має Бахмут.
Битва за це місто стала найдовшою та найкривавішою
з моменту широкомасштабного вторгнення Росії в Україну.
За словами одних експертів, українцям давно варто було відійти на вигідніші рубежі
та зберегти життя військових. Водночас інші оглядачі вважають, що
ціна утримання Бахмута виправдана і в тій "м'ясорубці перемололи"
значні сили вагнерівців та регулярних військ РФ, давши можливість Україні
підготувати резерви та освоїти західну бронетехніку.
Бахмут став пасткою для росіян.
Потрібно бачити битву у ширшій перспективі.
Росіяни пустили в хід все, що вони мали з серпня, і вони змогли захопити лише це місто.
Крім того, коли ви подивитеся на фото та відео з міста, там нічого не залишилося.
І проблема зараз у тому, що росіяни просто опиняться в районі, де вони, можливо,
навіть не зможуть залишатися в довгостроковій перспективі, тому що інфраструктури немає
і дуже важко утримувати місто у своїх руках.
Такої ж думки і керівник Центру військово-правових досліджень Олександр Мусієнко.
На його думку, тепер основне питання не в тому, хто контролює Бахмут, а в тому, як його втримати.
І росіянам це може обійтися великою ціною.
Ми бачимо, що українські війська зараз атакують по флангах, здобувають перевагу на флангах.
Для чого? Для того, щоб мати перевагу, враховуючи географічний ландшафт, тому що вони беруть висоти,
а Бахмут знаходиться переважно в низовині, в долині.
І відповідно до точки зору контролю вогневого, мінометного вогню, артилерійського,
це дає можливості, в принципі, знищувати російські війська, які будуть там.
Це справді нагадує битву за Сталінград, коли Вермахт фактично встановив контроль над Сталінградом,
та не зміг втримати зруйноване місто, каже Олександр Мусієнко.
Що зробили тоді радянські війська? Вони скористалися слабкістю німецьких флангів.
Точніше там були навіть не німці, а румуни, італійці, угорці, які контролювали ось ці фланги.
І вони скористалися слабкістю флангів, почали атакувати фланги.
Фланги почали тріскатися і сипатися. До чого це призвело?
Це призвело до того, що дії на флангах радянських військ фактично призвели до оточення Сталінграду.
І як наслідок армія Паулюса з Паулюсом на чолі вимушена була здаватися в полон.
В разі вдалої операції українських військ абсолютно буде подібна ситуація.
Українські війська атакують противника на флангах і створюють перспективу взяти місто в напівоточення.
Це дозволить перервати логістику і шляхи постачання росіян.
І російські війська, попри те, що вони заявили про перемогу, а що ж далі?
Чи можуть вони чогось досягти, піти далі на Часів Яр, на Костянтинівку, Дружківку, Краматорськ?
Не можуть. Їхній рух блокований, вони заблоковані зараз в Бахмуті.
Прорвати це напівоточення буде складно.
Знову ж таки, вони потребуватимуть додаткових сил, засобів і так далі, які вони будуть стягувати.
А Україна шляхом контролю цих висот буде мати можливість знищувати їх. І ось це ключове зараз.
Повідомлення про взяття Бахмута, за словами оглядачів, потрібні для російської пропаганди,
щоб показати хоч якийсь успіх на фронті за останній час з огляду на те,
що ЗСУ контратакують по флангах від Бахмута.
Українці повернули за останній час більше територій довкола Бахмута, ніж російські війська
захопили в українців. Тож саме українці просуваються. І річ у тому, що
війська Росії зараз не можуть просунутися вперед ніде на всій лінії фронту.
Ми можемо говорити лише про крихітне просування.
Тож важко уявити, що російські війська просуваються вперед із великим наступальним потенціалом.
Крім того, якщо зауважити, Пригожин зробив заяву саме про взяття Артемівська,
це колишня назва Бахмута. Але в цьому є важливий нюанс, каже експерт.
Це цікава річ, найменше звертають увагу.
Але Артемівськ до декомунізації і до реформи децентралізації
мав менші адміністративні межі, ніж має Бахмут. Це важливий нюанс.
І ви зверніть увагу, як Пригожин маніпулює словами.
Коли треба, він говорить "Бахмут", а коли він говорить про захоплення, він каже "Артемівськ".
Це цікавий момент. Це підтверджує версію українську про те, що там
певні околиці ще наші війська контролюють і можуть контролювати.
Таким чином Пригожин прагне відзвітувати про взяття Бахмута і вивести в тил свої війська,
щоб уникнути ризику оточення.
А от на плани українського контрнаступу ситуація в Бахмуті кардинально не вплине, вважають західні експерти,
і ЗСУ не потрібно концентруватися на поверненні міста під свій контроль.
Для мене південь має більш вирішальне значення, бо якщо український наступ на півдні
буде хоча б частково успішним і створить проблеми з логістикою для Криму,
то окремі регіони є сенс звільняти пізніше.
Я думаю, що питання, брати чи не брати Бахмут, не є вирішальним.
Тим часом битва за Бахмут триває.
Російські війська за 9 місяців змогли просунутися в цьому напрямку на захід лише на 33 кілометри,
витративши при цьому велику кількість техніки і засобів.
Натомість українська влада заявляє, що сили оборони здобувають успіхи на флангах.